>>> WE'RE GETTING NEW
INFORMATION ABOUT THE VIOLENT
MURDERS OF FOUR COLLEGE STUDENTS
IN IDAHO.
DETECTIVES REVEALING THE INITIAL
9-1-1 CALL CAME FROM ONE OF THE
SURVIVING ROOMMATE'S CELL
PHONES.
POLICE ALSO SAYING FOR THE FIRST
TIME THAT THERE WERE SEVERAL
OTHER FRIENDS AT THE HOUSE WHEN
THAT 9-1-1 CALL CAME IN, WHICH
OF COURSE WAS HOURS AFTER THE
ACTUAL MURDERS THEMSELVES.
NOW, DESPITE THE DETAILS, POLICE
TONIGHT STILL HAVE NO SUSPECT,
NO WEAPON, NO MOTIVE.
>> THIS INCIDENT HAS SHAKEN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND WE CONTINUE TO MOURN FOR THE
VICTIMS.
>> Reporter: MORE THAN A WEEK
AFTER THE KILLINGS OF FOUR
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO STUDENTS,
THE MYSTERY OVER WHO MURDERED
THEM ONLY DEEPENS.
AS INVESTIGATORS SEARCH THE
CRIME SCENE, POLICE REVEALING
WHO IS NOT CONSIDERED A SUSPECT.
BEGINNING WITH THE TWO ROOMMATES
ASLEEP IN THE HOME AS FOUR
OTHERS WERE STABBED TO DEATH.
>> HOW DOES ONE INDIVIDUAL KILL
FOUR PEOPLE AT NIGHT AND NOT
WAKE UP THE OTHER TWO ROOMMATES?
>> I DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
INFORMATION AT THIS POINT IN
TIME.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE CONTINUING
TO INVESTIGATE.
>> Reporter: BUT POLICE ABLE TO
CLEAR THE ROOMMATES AS SUSPECTS,
ADDING THAT ONE OF THEIR PHONES
WAS USED TO PLACE THE 9-1-1 CALL
JUST BEFORE NOON THAT DAY.
THE INITIAL CALLER NOT REVEALED,
AND POLICE SAY SEVERAL PEOPLE
TALKED TO THE DISPATCHER.
>> THERE WAS OTHER FRIENDS THAT
HAD ARRIVED AT THE LOCATION.
>> Reporter: THOSE FRIENDS FIRST
CALLED OVER BY THE ROOMMATES
WHEN THEY THOUGHT ONE OF THE
VICTIMS WAS PASSED OUT AND NOT
WAKING UP.
ALSO CLEARED AS A SUSPECT, A MAN
KAYLEE GONCALVES CALLED SEVERAL
TIMES.
HER FAMILY SAY IT'S WAS AN
EX-BOYFRIEND AND THAT THEY NEVER
SUSPECTED HIM.
>> HE IS NOT A SUSPECT.
HE IS NOT SUSPICIOUS.
HE IS 100% INNOCENT IN THIS.
>> Reporter: POLICE ALSO CLEARED
AS A SUSPECT SOMEONE SEEN IN
VIDEO FROM A FOOD TRUCK THAT TWO
OF THE VICTIMS VISITED THAT
NIGHT.
AND A DRIVER THAT PICKED UP
GONCALVES AND MADISON MOGEN WHO
PICKED THEM UP AFTER.
THE MURDER WEAPON, WE KNOW, IS A
FIXED-BLADE KNIFE, GENERALLY
MUCH STRONGER THAN A KITCHEN
KNIFE, AND COMMONLY USED IN
HUNTING.
POLICE SAY ALL FOUR VICTIMS WERE
LIKELY SLEEPING AT THE TIME OF
THE ATTACK.
BUT SOME POSSIBLY WOKE UP AND
DEFENDED THEMSELVES.
>> THERE WERE STAB WOUNDS ON THE
HANDS OF AT LEAST ONE OF THE
STUDENTS THAT MAKE IT APPEAR
THAT IT WOULD BE DEFENSIVE
WOUNDS.
>> Reporter: AUTHORITIES
CANVASSING NEIGHBORHOODS FOR
CLUES AND ADDITIONAL VIDEO AS
FLYERS READING "PLEASE HELP"
APPEARED AROUND THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
KAYLEE'S MOTHER TELLING NBC
SHE'S URGING THE KILLER TO END
THE MYSTERY.
>> THE GUILT HAS GOT TO BE JUST
OVERWHELMING.
IT'S GOT TO BE SICKENING.
STOP HIDING, STOP RUNNING.
>> Reporter: AND ALL OF THESE
FAMILIES WANT TO FIND THE
KILLER.
THEY WANT ANSWERS, THEY WANT
JUSTICE.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME THEY'RE ALSO
PLANNING FUNERALS.
ETHAN CHAPIN'S FUNERAL IS
HAPPENING AS WE SPEAK.
CAMERAS WERE NOT ALLOWED INSIDE
OF THE SERVICE.
BUT HIS MOTHER SPOKE BEFORE THAT
SERVICE.
SHE WAS EXTREMELY EMOTIONAL,
SAYING THAT HER SON IS ONE OF
THE MOST INCREDIBLE PEOPLE
YOU'LL EVER MEET.
THEY ASKED EVERYONE TO WEAR BLUE
BECAUSE HE IS A TRIPLET, AND
THAT IS HIS FAVORITE COLOR.
JOINING ME IS HOST OF HLN'S REAL
LIFE NIGHTMARE.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS CASE SO
FAR, PARTICULARLY WHAT SEEMS TO
BE THE SCARCITY OF INFORMATION
OR AT LEAST LACK OF PUBLICLY
RELEASED INFORMATION.
DO YOU THINK THAT MAYBE
AUTHORITIES KNOW MORE THAN
THEY'RE REVEALING?
>> WELL, THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT AUTHORITIES KNOW MORE THAN
WHAT THEY'RE REVEALING BUT I
THINK AS I'M WATCHING THIS CASE,
AND WATCH IT UNFOLD, I THINK
AUTHORITIES ARE STILL TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DEALING WITH.
YOU KNOW, INITIALLY THEY CAME
OUT AND SAID THIS APPEARS TO BE
A TARGETED ATTACK.
THERE'S NO CONCERN TO THE REST
OF THE PUBLIC.
BUT THEN SINCE THEN, THEY HAVE
RETRACTED THAT, AND I BELIEVE AS
THEY INVESTIGATE THIS CASE,
THEY'RE STARTING TO REALIZE IT'S
MAYBE MORE COMPLICATED THAN WHAT
THEY FIRST THOUGHT.
>> HOW SO?
>> WELL, I BELIEVE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS THAT YOU HAVE FOUR
VICTIMS.
AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A HUGE
CASE.
IT'S VERY COMPLICATED.
AND WHEN THEY WENT INTO THIS
CRIME SCENE, THEY LIKELY SAW
THAT MAYBE ONE OR TWO OF THE
VICTIMS HAD MORE VIOLENCE
INFLICTED ON THEM.
THE OFFENDER SPENT MORE TIME
WITH THEM, AND THEY THOUGHT,
OKAY, THESE WERE THE INTENDED
TARGETS, AND THAT THE OTHER
VICTIMS IN THE HOUSE WERE
SECONDARY.
SO THEY FOCUSED THEIR INITIAL
INVESTIGATION THINKING, OKAY,
IT'S GOING TO BE SOMETHING, A
RELATIONSHIP, SOME SORT OF PRIOR
INTERACTION THAT THE OFFENDER
HAD WITH THOSE PARTICULAR
VICTIMS.
HOWEVER, WHEN THAT DIDN'T PAN
OUT, NOW I THINK WHAT THEY'RE
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY THAT THE OFFENDER,
THE KILLER, IS A COMPLETE
STRANGER TO THESE VICTIMS AND
THAT THE REASON THAT THEY'RE
SEEING THAT SOME OF THE VICTIMS
HAD MORE VIOLENCE ON THEM WAS
DUE TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES AS THE
VIOLENCE WAS BEING INFLICTED.
>> THE DETAILS WE MENTIONED
ABOUT THE HOURS LEADING UP TO
THE MURDERS, HOW CRUCIAL IS THE
TIME LINE, AND MAYBE HOW FAR
WOULD YOU GO BACK LOOKING?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE TIME LINE
IS ABSOLUTELY CRUCIAL.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THAT NIGHT,
WHILE THE VICTIMS ARE OUT, YOU
KNOW, ENJOYING THEIR COLLEGE
YEARS THAT THE OFFENDER COULD
HAVE INTERACTED WITH THEM OR
HAVE SEEN THEM AND FOLLOWED THEM
BACK.
SO THAT IS ABSOLUTELY MANDATED
TO FOLLOW UP ON.
HOWEVER, RIGHT NOW THEY'VE ONLY
RELEASED INFORMATION OF THE
VICTIMS' TIME LINES FOR THAT
EVENING, AND OFTENTIMES KILLERS
MAKE THE DECISION TO KILL WITHIN
72 HOURS, THREE DAYS BEFORE THE
ATTACK.
SO THEY NEED TO GO BACK AND
ACTUALLY FIGURE OUT, WELL,
WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON IN THESE
VICTIMS' LIVES THREE DAYS PRIOR
TO THIS ATTACK IF NOT FURTHER.
>> WE HAVE ABOUT 30 SECONDS
LEFT, CAN YOU WRAP YOUR HEAD
AROUND THE FACT THAT THERE WERE
TWO OTHER ROOMMATES WHO SEEM TO
HAVE SLEPT THROUGH THE MURDERS
AND WERE NOT ATTACKED?
>> YOU KNOW, FROM AFAR, YOU HAVE
SIX PEOPLE INSIDE THIS HOUSE.
FOUR ARE KILLED.
FOR ME, WHERE ARE THESE VICTIMS
INSIDE THE HOUSE.
THESE TWO ROOMMATES MAY HAVE
BEEN MORE ISOLATED THAN THE
OTHER VICTIMS WERE.
THAT'S WHY THEY WERE SPARED OR
THEY WEREN'T THE TARGET OF THIS
PARTICULAR OFFENDER.
>> PAUL HOLZ, WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME HELPING US TO UNDERSTAND
WHICH AT THIS POINT IS STILL A
REALLY BIG MYSTERY.